about the best practices he's clearly
thinking about marketing from a direct
response click attribution tactical
standpoint that's like saying I don't
get what being on TV all the time does
for my business because nobody's
clicking from their TV and buying Kelly
Ripa's book so what he is is he's base
he's bait you tell your man that he's
basic thinking he's thinking one chess
move it's called branding there's two
separate things one's called branding
one's called sales he's talking sales
that's one step right you go on Google
you buy an ad you click it you sell
that's a sale but branding is different
what does Taylor Swift get out of like
surprising a fan and bringing them on
stage she think in a transaction nobody
touched the screen and bought her album
she built brand it made you think
something like so they're thinking to
basic snapchat I've thirty thousand
people watching every one of my snapchat
stories right I snapped me walking into
here what didn't click it and bought my
book but I'm painting a narrative of my
life they're becoming interested and
then when I asked for it somewhere else
tactically so I'm playing chess and I
think your man's playing checkers
you